Personne n'en veut ? Je peux finir ?
Non, non, ça ira.
Non, merci.
Bah qu'est ce que t'as ?
T'es fatiguée ? Tu fais la gueule ?
Non, ça va je fais pas la gueule...
Je suis pas obligée de sourire tout le temps.
Non, t'es pas obligée, non.
Fini ta soupe, t'as rien touché.
Non mais j'ai pas très faim là.
Je crois que je suis un peu ballonnée.
Bah c'est pas grave.
T'es pas obligée de finir tout hein.
Non mais vraiment j'ai envie de vomir.
Elle veut plus manger de soupe.
Mais ta gueule toi !
Quoi ? Comment ça ?
Bah elle pense qu'on est des meurtriers !
Mais vas-y ! Arrête !
Doucement les enfants là hein.
Oh ! Oh ! On se calme.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Oh !
Qu'est ce qu'il se passe ?
Pourquoi tu veux plus manger de soupe ?
Je veux plus manger d'animaux c'est tout.
C'est juste des terriens hein.
Oui bah c'est mignon les terriens.
Moi j'ai pas envie qu'on les tue.
J'ai l'impression de boire du sang là.
On parle de la même chose là ?
C'est con et moche comme ses pieds un terrien.
En plus je te les ai fait macéré comme tu aimes.
On devrait pas tuer des êtres vivants, c'est tout.
Bon... je vois.
Tu sais, il faut savoir qu'ils ont pas du tout le même niveau de conscience que nous.
Les terriens c'est tout petits.
Ça a un cerveau minuscule hein.
Ça fabrique des voitures en métal...
Ça chie dans des cuves en céramique hein.
Et bah moi, les imaginer se faire tuer ça me suffit, voilà.
Ecoute, ils sont très bien traités, ils vivent très bien.
En plus, ceux que j'ai acheté sont bio.
Bah oui, regarde !
Ceux-là, ils courent dans les près.
C'est pas comme ceux qu'on voit à la télé...
Qui s'entassent dans des villes polluées, non.
Regarde, ceux-là, ils sont libres.
Mais maman, parfois on les tue à 16 ans !
Super la liberté !
Ecoute, on va pas manger de la viande avariée.
Tu sais, eux ils croient qu'ils vivent sur un caillou rond dans l'espace.
Ils ont pas du tout conscience qu'ils sont récoltés, tu sais ?
Ok !
Donc en fait, plus un animal est con, plus on fait ce qu'on veut de lui, c'est ça ?
Dans ce cas, pourquoi est-ce qu'on mangerait pas Boubou ?
Tu vas pas t'en prendre à Boubou non ?
Ecoute pas Boubou.
Boubou !
Bah quoi ? Je sais pas. On a qu'à l'écraser, comme ça, il ne se rend compte de rien.
Et puis on ferait une petite purée de Boubou, c'est pas mal ça.
Qu'est ce que tu en penses ?
Oui. D'une certaine façon, tu as raison.
Nous sommes des assassins.
Donc on arrête les terriens ?
Non.